buenas tardes vamos a empezar
por hablar sobre la corporización que es
por qué y para qué bueno está
corporización empieza esta historia
empieza en el siglo 17 con la concepción
humanista del hombre donde aquí nuestro
amigo descartes
divide al hombre en dos sustancias mente
y cuerpo y promulga que el cuerpo es tan
solo
un contenedor de nuestra mente es un
daño colateral de nuestra existencia y
por tanto lo que nos define como hombres
solo y exclusivamente radicalmente
pues bien de aquellos lodos estos barros
aparecen en las distintas disciplinas
que estudian por un lado la mente le
hace psicología psicopedagogía pedagogía
y aquellas disciplinas que estudian el
cuerpo como pueda ser la neurociencia la
neurofisiología traumatología a veces
disciplina estas disciplinas distintos
ámbitos pues pueden trabajar o han
trabajado de manera conjunta a veces en
modo isla y a veces incluso
contradiciéndose las unas a las otras en
sus postulados pues bien a toda la
hipótesis como bien se promulga tercera
ley de newton de las hipótesis a toda
hipótesis aparece siempre una contra
hipótesis y aparece a principios de este
siglo la concepción de corporización o
en dormir
esta corporización según esta hipótesis
pues promulga que el cuerpo conforma el
modo en el que pensamos con lo cual es
imposible poder entender los procesos
cognitivos inherentes a nosotros todo
hombre y toda persona dejando al margen
su naturaleza biológica de acuerdo a
esta hipótesis
pues el objetivo primario por tanto de
nuestro sistema nervioso central será
facilitar la interacción de nuestro
cuerpo con nuestro entorno y para que
veamos un ejemplo de la importancia del
sistema nervioso central de nuestro
sistema nervioso central en esta
interacción con nuestro nuestro medio
pues tenemos aquí abajo
en este dibujito un pequeño gusano de
mar así díaz se llaman que en su estado
larvario tiene un sistema nervioso
central primitivo que le permite nadar
como si fuese uno en la cual un pequeño
renacuajo este gusanito de mar cuando se
ancla a su piedra la piedra la que va a
pasar el resto de su vida la primera
comida que tiene del día es su sistema
nervioso central no puede permitirse el
lujo de tener un sistema nervioso
central si no se va a mover pues bien
una vez que sabemos de esta importancia
y sabemos cuál es el objetivo de nuestro
sistema nervioso central pues nosotros
estudiamos
el cerebelo que es un subsistema que nos
permite coordinar todos los movimientos
de nuestros músculos mediante el cerebro
nosotros podemos bailar
nosotros podemos correr y lo que es más
importante nosotros pudimos cazar
coordinando nuestros movimientos pudimos
cambiar nuestra dieta ya no teníamos que
estar rumiando todo el día por ahí y nos
permitió sentarnos a pensar quiénes
somos y qué estamos haciendo aquí
pero bueno una vez que nosotros
conocemos vamos a estudiar el cerebelo
que es el sistema que nos permite esa
interacción cuerpo cuerpo entorno en
primer grado
usted debemos conocer todas y cada uno
los elementos digamos los elementos que
conforman este cerebelo elementos
fundamentales que conforman este
cerebelo aquí pues podemos decir que
esos elementos son las neuronas que
podemos asimilar las pequeñas baterías
unas baterías que en esa interacción con
nuestro entorno van cargándose y
descargándose esas baterías pero
nosotros vamos moviendo esas neuronas
tienen un potencial de membrana o no a
tener una carga como la que podemos
tener nuestro móvil y se van cargando y
se van descargando conforme nosotros
vamos moviéndonos en un momento en el
que una de las neuronas por ejemplo aquí
se carga emite un impulso ese impulso
viaja de una neurona origen a una
neurona destino y cuando llega a esa
neurona destino modifica su estado el
estado
de su carga
este proceso se va enterando a lo largo
de esta interacción con nuestro entorno
dándose lo que nosotros conocemos como
código neuronal el conjunto de impulsos
que van viajando a lo largo del tiempo
así como los potentes estos potenciales
de membrana esta estas cargas de estas
neuronas es bueno confort conforman lo
que nosotros denominamos grossomodo
un código neuronal pues bien como
podemos nosotros descifrar cuáles son
las herramientas tecnologías que
nosotros tenemos para poder descifrar
ese código neuronal
pues bien tecnológicamente nosotros
estamos dotados de resonancia magnética
con lo cual podemos hacer registros
neuronales de determinadas poblaciones
con una cierta resolución tenemos
también encefalograma y tenemos
electrodo donde podemos conseguir con
una resolución mucho más precisa porque
son realmente agujas que nosotros
podemos colocar directamente sobre el
cerebelo y podemos registrar esa
actividad neuronal podemos tener
registros de ese código neuronal
conforme nosotros nos podemos nos vamos
desplazando y vamos interactuando con
nuestro entorno problema que tenemos con
esta tecnología porque no podemos
codificar no podemos perdón no podemos
datar no podemos almacenar toda la
información que nosotros necesitamos o
que se da en esa interacción buen cuerpo
entorno el problema sería algo parecido
a tener un libro en el cual nosotros
sólo tenemos palabras sueltas en ese
libro
tenemos espacios en blanco nosotros
debemos de dar contexto a su espacio en
blanco para poder entender qué es lo que
nos transmite ese libro de acuerdo pues
bien es aquí donde entra lo que no es mi
equipo bueno mi grupo de investigación
está haciendo lo que nosotros conocemos
como neurociencia computacional nosotros
con esta neurociencia computacional
tratamos de dar contexto a esos espacios
en blanco que tenemos de nuestro código
neuronal allí donde no podemos llegar
con la tecnología el proceso que
nosotros seguimos es un proceso
constructivo en el cual nosotros
comenzamos modelando lo que son las
neuronas están algunas de las que hemos
hablado lo que nosotros modelamos
mediante ecuaciones matemáticas son los
procesos de carga y descarga de estas
neuronas y de comunicación vía impulso
una vez que tenemos estos modelos de
neuronas porque no tenemos bueno tenemos
distintos tipos de neuronas igual que
tenemos distintos tipo de baterías pues
hay distintos tipos de neuronas que se
cargan de una manera u otra y que emiten
impulsos que emiten esos pulsos de
manera diferente una vez que tenemos
todas
abanico de neuronas nosotros debemos de
interconectar la como la interconectados
por afortunadamente como el cerebelo es
una estructura muy muy regular podemos
replicar esa estructura en el segundo
nivel una vez que tenemos esa topografía
tenemos esa topología de red perdón una
vez que tenemos auto po logía de red
pues debemos de corporizar las demos
buscar un cuerpo en el cual podamos
probar si realmente esto que estamos
nosotros creando este sistema neuronal
este cerebelo que estamos nosotros
creando es funcional
pues bien esto es un poco un ejemplo de
lo que nosotros producimos como tenemos
un corte aquí de una capa granular de
revelar el cual vemos distintas neuronas
vemos como esas neuronas se van
encendiéndose y apagándose lo que quiere
decir que están emitiendo pulsos
impulsos y están recibiendo impulso cada
mes a medida que nosotros vamos
desplazando y una vez que tenemos este
pedazo de esta red funcionando ahora
mismo necesitamos pues dotarla de un
cuerpo puesto que sería el equivalente a
tener una especie de trozos de carne
pues no tendremos ningún cuerpo que
conectarse no tiene funciona de ninguna
y nosotros decidimos buscar pues saber
un cuerpo al cual podamos aplicar al que
podemos incorporarle este sistema
neuronal este este este cerebelo porque
miramos en nuestro entorno y bueno nos
fijamos en los robots
hay grosso modo hablando dos tipos dos
grandes familias de robots los robots
industriales que probablemente todos
hayamos visto alguna vez que están
metidos en jaulas como si fuesen
animales peligrosos estos robos
industriales aquí a la izquierda son
robots que están preparados para hacer
una tarea de manera muy eficiente
repetitiva en el tiempo si son robots
peligrosos porque no permiten
interacción a ellos
digamos que tienen que hacer una tarea
para ir de un punto a un punto b sin
tener en cuenta lo que hay en medio no
están preparados para interaccionar con
nosotros de hecho si hay un humano que
esté dentro del perímetro de seguridad
de ese robot es el humano tiene peligro
lo griego de muerte
pues bien nosotros nos fijamos en una
segunda familia en un robot que se le
denomina humanoides son robots que
sustituyen o que imitan digamos a
nuestros tendones ya nuestros músculos
sustituyéndolos por muelles y por él y
por cable cable acerado y bueno una vez
que bueno estos son robots que se
empezaron a desarrollar a los 90 y
digamos que la última interacción que
tenemos después es mucho más
evolucionada una vez que tenemos el
cuerpo pues debemos de probar si
realmente nuestro nuestro cerebelo
nuestro sistema el sistema nervioso
central que hemos hecho pues funciona
para ello necesitamos probarlo con un
test que se nos ocurrió
bueno pues utilizamos uno de los test el
reflejo vestíbulo ocular que se utiliza
para comprobar si hay alguna anomalía
cerebral puesto que nuestros ojos están
directamente los músculos que acciona
nuestros ojos están directamente
conexionado tienen una conexión directa
con nuestro cerebelo en este reflejo
este reflejo no es un reflejo
nature nosotros debemos aprenderlo
cuando nacemos no conseguimos realizar
este reflejo bueno este reflejo como
veis en la imagen consiste en compensar
sencillamente los movimientos laterales
de nuestra cabeza con movimientos contra
las telares de nuestros ojos nos permite
andar de manera con un equilibrio y por
ejemplo también nos permite conducir
sobre una carretera bacheada pudiendo
fijar la mirada
sí
pues bien una vez que tenemos
todo tenemos el conjunto todas las
piezas del puzzle pues nosotros
decidimos incorporar un sistema
vestibular a un robot como el que
tenemos en la imagen este robot se llama
ay qué se hizo se hizo en el instituto
tecnológico italiano y lo que como vemos
aquí al principio del aprendizaje tanto
cabeza como ojos se mueven de manera
solidaria que lo que vemos en las
pequeñas flechas que hay abajo en la
imagen
esas flechas indican que la imagen no
está estable mientras más grandes las
flechas menos estabilidad y en la imagen
y conforme nuestro cerebro va
aprendiendo de la misma manera que
nosotros aprendemos conseguimos
estabilizar
la mirada del robot como vemos la imagen
está mucho más estable
lo hicimos con distintos ángulos con lo
cual pudimos podemos ver que era capaz
de interpol a ese aprendizaje era capaz
de interponerse entre distintos grados y
distintos planos
pues una vez comprobado todas y cada una
de las mecanismos fundamentales de
funcionamiento de nuestra red neuronal
pasamos a algo un poquito más complejo
ya está validado vamos a ver cómo
logramos cierta interacción utilizamos
aquí otro tipo de robot antropomórfico
baxter en el cual nosotros lo sometemos
también a distintos procesos de
aprendizaje tal cual nosotros tendríamos
en casa aquí va que se les está haciendo
la tarea de mover en mover un círculo
como si estuviésemos batiendo la
mayonesa algo parecido y al principio
sería algo equivalente a mover un palo o
un palito que no tiene peso sino una
cuchara digamos que tenemos una cuchara
estamos batiendo y es un tenedor y
sostenedores de plástico y pesa poco sin
embargo aquí ignacio le coloca una pesa
eso sería algo equivalente a que esa
cuchara pues tuviera un peso mucho mayor
y nosotros de manera natural
inferimos que esa cuchara cambia el peso
y nosotros somos capaces de seguir
realizando esa misma tarea pero con
distinta herramientas
segundo segundo tenés que nosotros
realizamos fue someter a este tipo de
robots a este tipo de cerebelo y de
aprendizaje con este tipo de robots a un
elemento elástico
nosotros estamos rodeados de elementos
también rígidos pero también muchos
elásticos cuya interacción es mucho más
compleja puesto que la fuerza que
nosotros debemos ejercer no es siempre
constante en el módulo en un sentido si
vimos que para acceder a capaz de
entender que estaba interactuando con
una fuerza que no era siempre igual y
por tanto pudo nuestro cerebro aprender
a compensar la existencia de esa banda
elástica finalmente en una batería de
experimentos lo que hicimos fue
realmente interaccionar e interactuar
con el robot la primera interacción
consistía en presionar a pasteur igual
que nosotros podemos presionar al
compañero podemos empujar le con un dedo
con la mínima fuerza para que ser fuerte
aquí hemos combinado lo presiona sobre
una de las articulaciones y él es capaz
de entender que hay alguien que hay una
fuerza externa hay alguien alrededor y
pone la mínima fuerza para no hacer daño
la siguiente siguiente prueba fue la de
poder la extremidad d backs el
poder moverla poder articular la de la
misma manera que nosotros porque se
aumentará interactuando con otras
personas con su brazo lo coge del
antebrazo y lo coge del que sería el
bíceps y vemos cómo entiende cerebelo
que hay alguien que hay una persona que
está ahí y que por tanto debe ejercer la
mínima fuerza para no dañar no hacer
daño él aprende que se ocurre finalmente
en un escenario plausible es un golpeo
circunstancial de una persona con otra
nosotros al igual que hizo el cerebelo
entendemos que estamos ante un elemento
flexible y por tanto
damos o ponemos la mínima fuerza
necesaria con la finalidad de no dañar
bueno pues como esto es un trabajo
colaborativo entre distintas
universidades y bueno como conclusión
pues sólo deciros que entender el código
neuronal que genera nuestro sistema
nervioso central es cuando interactuamos
con nuestro entorno no tan solo y no
sólo nos permite ahondar en aquellos
procesos cognitivos que nos definen sino
también podemos llegar a entender mejor
aquellas enfermedades neuronales que
están relacionadas con él con el
movimiento le hace parkinson huntington
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]